if you want to see just how radical how
extreme Democrats have become on
immigration
check out the freaks at their anti-ice
protests the siege of the at the
portland oregon ice building started on
june 17th and continues today o testers
even followed them home to the
residences followed them when they went
to pick up their kids at daycare
repeatedly threatening their lives this
was an absolute siege of a nice facility
a lot of people don't know this this
really isn't getting covered out in the
mainstream media we lost that building
for ten days almost two weeks
the protesters took control at that
building and these were again these were
not normal protesters this you know
folks like an Tifa violent militant
groups haven't seen the media coverage
of that aspect of it we're gonna get
into more in just a moment we have new
information for you tonight but to top
it all off Portland mayor Ted wheeler
shot down the terrified ice officers
calls for help saying that police would
respond to them quote when there were
imminent life safety threats okay
and last week we are taught
demonstrators to peacefully disengage
for their own safe safety heck with the
safety of the ice employees this is
totally out of control and it's
backfiring big time on the Democrats a
recent Reuters Ipsos poll found that
immigration was the top issue for us
voters heading into the November 2018
midterm elections it edged out even the
economy and it's hard to believe that
the voters concern about immigration
here is focused on what the left wants
to do this phony concern for the kids at
the border I don't think so
remember not so long ago Democrats at
least gave lip service to our basic
right to border enforcement it is wrong
and ultimately self-defeating for a
nation of immigrants to permit the kind
of abuse of our immigration laws we have
seen in recent years illegal immigration
is wrong
and a primary goal of comprehensive
immigration reform must be to
dramatically curtail future illegal
immigration
look I voted numerous times when I was a
senator to spend money to build a a
barrier to try to prevent illegal
immigrants from coming in and remember
this from President Obama back in 2014
who sounded a lot like Trump on this
issue except for the no protests or
marches part do not send your children
to the borders if they do make it
they'll get sent back more importantly
they may not make it back but instead of
warning of the dangers of making family
treks across the border like President
Obama just did the new more antifa
friendly Democrats warned about an
America that actually punishes border
jumpers and they are never happier on
the Left when they're than when they're
using kids as political pawns I've heard
of the stories and with ice year-old
infants being before the the judges in
it it's almost Kefka chuck-e-cheese uses
things like this to check parents in
their children when they're they're okay
with that absurd analysis Vermont would
be better off with the Chuckie Cheese
mascot
it's one of their senators oh my god Oh
Chuckie Cheese does a better job of
keeping parents again here is a nice
official Matthew Albin attempting to
introduce this concept called applying
the facts to the law to this Democrat
senator from Hawaii
mazie Hirono again I think we're missing
the point
these individuals are there because they
have broken a law there has to be a
process they have broken a law only as
deemed so by the president with his no
ma'am they're there for violation of
title eight of the immigrations illegal
entry is both a criminal and civil
violation they man
my understanding is that other
zero-tolerance these are no longer
circle civil proceedings but in fact for
criminal proceedings
they're both I'm confused okay okay
god bless her she's confused as all that
okay volcanic ash blowing across Hawaii
begun to affect the good Senators
cognitive skills what part don't you
understand laws on the books violate the
laws there will be a penalty and the
pundits wonder how Trump got elected out
of the roughly 2500 children who are
separated from their family units at the
us-mexico border more than 1,800 have
already been reunited with their parents
and of the 700 children or so who still
not been reunited 431 have parents now
outside the United States those parents
were either deported or voluntarily
abandoned their children a fact that is
conveniently omitted from the DEM Tifa
crowd democrats wailing over the plight
of the remaining children are completely
ignoring the facts due to domestic or
drug abuse many of these parents are now
deemed unfit to care for their children
or dangerous for their children so
newsflash the US government is
protecting the border kids today or
order order the Democrats want them to
be reunited with parents who could
traffic them or who are criminals
themselves is that what they want and by
the way the kids who may have a chance
of being deported back home to be in
their homeland with their parents are
now being blocked in a lawsuit by the
ACLU by the way wasn't that American
Civil Liberties Union now it's illegal
immigrant Civil Liberties Union in the
meantime we're caring for these children
and the US taxpayers are footing the
bill but who cares about these facts
when peddling emotion dripping with
concern is so much easier Melania Trump
went to the border and asked these empty
questions about when and how these
families will be put back together
she doesn't care she's planning
Christmas at the White House are you
idiots running this country
you seem like child abusers to me ask
any doctor ask any child where welfare
specialist ask any psychiatrist ask
yourself is this abuse this is abuse
that was abuse just watching that you
ever notice how the empathy though just
runs one way it's never the same kind of
empathy for the families victimized by
violent illegal alien crime or DWI
deaths because of illegal immigrants or
drug trafficking gun-running never any
empathy for Americans who've been pushed
out of their jobs in the workforce for
cheaper illegal labor never any empathy
for ice agents who have their reputation
smeared or lives threatened for just
doing their jobs our commitment to
consistent and fair enforcement of the
law is demonstrated on a daily basis by
the integrity the unbiased
professionalism and the compassion that
the men and women of CBP exhibit towards
the aliens we encounter particularly
towards the most vulnerable we do not
leave our humanity behind when we report
for duty
that's a great line now Americans are
just a lot smarter let's face it than
the left and their media poodles think
Americans understand that we are not a
country without borders of course we
have compassion that's why we're taking
as I think pretty good care of them all
things considered they're not with their
families but they're being fed clothed
doctor's appointments entertainment
sports schooling interpreters lawyers
that's not nothing
and Americans will not be guilted into
supporting politicians who put the
interests of illegal aliens ahead of our
own citizens here's why congressman Ron
De Santis will be the next governor of
Florida he gets it we can fight illegal
immigration all we got to do is enact
even
and stop sanctuary cities we want
maximum border security and respect for
our heroes eyes Border Patrol and law
enforcement and we're going to have
tremendous border security that will
include the wall that will include the
wall the applause went on and on last
night the biggest applause lines when
the issue of immigration came up look
it's in my mind it's actually sad it's
really sad to see what's happened to the
party of FDR and John F Kennedy the
Democrat Party on this issue and so many
others they used to believe America was
worth defending her laws her
Constitution the Declaration her borders
her history now they're most vocal
voices believe it's time to destroy that
old order and replace it with something
kind of closer to socialism but we're
not about to let that happen and that's
the angle